the story of Perseus and Medusa is
perhaps one of the most well known
stories in the entirety of Greek
mythology and it's definitely one that
elicits a very strong emotional reaction
whenever I discuss either Medusa or
Athena I always see the exact same
question in the comment section why
would Athena help Medusa but then help
Perseus kill her now this of course
refers back to the role that Athena
played in Medusa's transformation
specifically the version where Athena
turned Medusa into a Gorgon as a means
of protection
Athena than helping Perseus kill Medusa
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to a
lot of people why give someone the means
to protect themselves if you're just
gonna kill them anyway
now my problem with this specific
question is not the question itself it's
that most people asking it don't seem to
want an answer they don't want to
examine the story they want to take the
stance that Medusa was treated unfairly
and so everything that followers must be
this great injustice
Perseus isn't the hero of this story
he's just the villain Athena isn't the
goddess of wisdom she's just jealous and
evil I'm so upset that they killed my
queen Medusa that I'm gonna ignore all
of the other characters and whatever
motives they may have because Medusa is
the only one that matters now if you do
approach a story from this bubble where
Medusa is the only important character
that the entire story centers around not
only are you entirely wrong but you'll
never understand the story nor any of
its characters for the sake of context
persistant just walk into Medusa's lair
and kill her without any reason to
summarize this story Perseus was sent by
King Polydectes to retrieve Medusa's
head as a gift in the hopes that he
would be slain in the process with
Perseus out of the picture there would
be no one left to stop him marrying his
mother not trust in the king and wanting
to avoid this entire situation
Perseus accepted the request and vowed
to bring back the gift that he promised
if we look at the oldest depictions the
Medusa was born a Gorgon so this entire
transformation process never actually
happened Medusa and Athena don't really
have a connection and so there's no real
conflict of interest when it comes to
Athena then help in Perseus the only
version of the story where this question
can even be applied to is where Athena
transforms Medusa because she wanted to
help her because here you can make the
argument that assist in Perseus
effectively undoes everything that she
had previously done where this argument
kind of falls flat on its face is the
fact of
other characters in this story and
Medusa is certainly not the central
figure this is very much Perseus his
story retrieving the head of Medusa is
just one small part of his overall
journey
Perseus needin help then turn to Athena
who along with the other gods gave him
various trinkets and weapons to aid him
on his quest many also believe that
Athena guided he sword when he actually
beheaded Medusa so why exactly did
Athena help Perseus after she had
already helped Medusa
first of all with Sina was a hero's
patron and Perseus wasn't just any hero
he was also her half-brother so when a
hero who also happens to be your brother
comes to you in need of assistance a
goddess as loyal as Athena would never
turn away family and refused her duties
because she had previously helped
someone else the family comes first as a
sentiment and I'm sure many people agree
with and it's very likely that Athena
would always prioritize Perseus over
Medusa just because she helped Medusa
once doesn't mean she owes her an
eternity of protection it's also
entirely possible that Athena made a
mistake
Medusa's transformation may not have had
a desired effect or outcome it's no
secret that after a transformation
Medusa's life would have changed and
most likely not for the best
she would have been driven into
isolation and even hunted as a trophy
not a life that sounds particularly
enjoyable what was meant as a way to
give Medusa the power to protect herself
ended up just completely isolating her
from the world around her Athena perhaps
regretting her decision could have seen
helping Perseus as a way of releasing
Medusa from what she perceived to be a
miserable existence while still being
able to help Perseus at the same time or
maybe Athena being as pragmatic as she
was weight each alternative and decided
that Medusa's head would do more good
than she would be capable of while alive
deciding that it would be for the
greater good there are numerous reasons
why Athena would help Perseus kill
Medusa but it mostly just depends on
which interpretation of the story that
you choose to believe realistically
there's no real way for us to know
exactly why and these are just some of
my own theories so feel free to agree or
disagree but if you do have your own
theories then please share them so I
guess this is where I segue into plug in
our book for those who don't know a good
friend of mine and I have been working
on a book based on Greek mythology that
retells some of our favorite stories one
of the stories details Medusa's life as
a mortal and the events that led to her
transformation it's a take on Medusa
that we don't really see much and I
think it's one of the rare occasions
where she's actually given a personality
and
is more than just a character caught in
someone else's story the book is
scheduled to be released on January 15th
B can pre-order your Kindle and
hardcover versions now on Amazon and
most major book retailers I'll leave a
link in the description in the comments
for you guys to click on I do honestly
really enjoy these more theory based
videos as opposed to always explained in
something if it's something you guys
would like to see more of them please
leave any questions that you'd like to
see me attempt to answer as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explain